of humanity I actually tweeted this out
I wonder what you guys think about this
if a republic hacked its own election to
prevent a psychotic mob from taking over
the government democratically
why I thought that some You could argue
that that might be righteous and I'm
interested what you guys think about it
no I think like say there's a group of
psychotic murderers that want to cut
people open as their cult ritual and
there's more enough of them that they
can democratically mob rule the vote
system and win don't we have a republic
intentionally to prevent that
well sort of I mean first if you're
talking about people violating human
rights in the Constitution then they
would be in violation of of our
government which is why the Constitution
is so important if a group of weirdo
Cults who are like if you vote for us
we'll sacrifice children on an altar at
a pyramid to moloch or whatever like
overtly saying it and trying to do it
then it wouldn't be those attempting to
stop it would actually be on the side of
the
console